avec ce président nous sommes devenus
plus faibles plus malades
plus pauvres plus divisé plus violents
quand j'étais vice-président nous avons
hérité d'une récession
on m'a demandé de la réparer je les fais
nous lui avons laissé une économie en
plein essor
il a causé la récession une attaque
lourde de sens
donald trump comptait jouer sa campagne
sur ses bons résultats économiques mais
l'épidémie de kobe 19 est venue
contrarier ses plans le coronavirus a
détruit plusieurs millions d'emplois et
les etats-unis sont entrés en récession
au deuxième trimestre 2000 20 après une
chute historique du pib de 32,9 % pour
relancer l'économie le candidat
républicain compte ainsi créer 10
millions d'emplois en dix mois et un
million de petites entreprises des
promesses sans détails pour le moment du
côté démocrate
l'idée est simple pour joe biden s'il
est élu les américains les plus riches
et les grosses entreprises paieront 4
milliards de dollars d'impôts
supplémentaires sur les dix prochaines
années
quand le cours de la bourse monte ça
signifie des emplois
ça signifie aussi des pensions si vous
arrivez un jour si vous veniez président
avec vos idées vous voulez mettre fin à
mon impôt à mes impôts je vais vous dire
vous allez perdre la moitié des
entreprises qui se sont rués ici vont
partir elles vont s'en aller à d'autres
endroits
malgré cette menace ce plan de relance
servira également à réinvestir dans des
programmes sociaux et dans l'éducation
mais surtout dans les infrastructures
dont la modernisation est un vieux
serpent de mer aux états unis présenté
comme le candidat de la classe moyenne
joe biden a promis également de remonter
le salaire minimal fédéral de 7,25
dollars de l'heure inchangée depuis 2009
à 15 dollars
l' agence moody's analytics a conduit
récemment une étude comparée des
propositions économiques des deux
candidats selon elle un second mandat de
donald trump perpétuerait les baisses
d'impôt ayant surtout bénéficié aux
grosses fortunes et aux entreprises lors
de son premier mandat
à noter également que le plein emploi
disparu avec la crise ducobu 19 ne serai
de retour qu'au premier trimestre 2001
24 avec les républicains alors qu'il
reviendrait aux
deuxième semestre 2022 dans l'hypothèse
démocrate
l'analyse de moody's a révélé qu'une
victoire de donald trump serait un
résultat pire pour l'économie
en raison de ces propositions de relance
budgétaire plus modestes et de la
probabilité accrue de tensions
commerciales plus profondes et de
réduction de l'immigration
une analyse qui se base uniquement sur
des hypothèses mais qui tend à montrer
qu'une victoire de joe biden sur donald
trump et une vague démocrate au sénat
entraînerait à priori un meilleur
rebondissements de la croissance
économique et de l'emploi aux états unis
à condition d'avoir une majorité au
congrès pour mettre pleinement en oeuvre
cette politique économique